The Joe Rogan experience.
Um,
so you've have you never written your act down?
no I couldn't.
I used,
see I used to do sketch comedy,
like,
like a Monty python thing and I wrote those and then I was doing a street full
of for four years.
And that's very unwritten.
I know that's very difficult,
right.
It's difficult to actually develop material for that.
So I did that for four years.
So I got into this thing of,
well I'll do performing like how,
so what would you do?
Um,
we,
we were double act initially.
Me and my partner rob and we did weigh things are escaping from a wooly jumper.
He just wrap a wooly jumper.
I returned to escape wooly jumper.
What does that Willie Cardigan we really pull over?
Pull over.
Okay.
Yeah.
I got sweater.
Yes.
Sweater.
Yeah.
So instead of a straight jacket,
he said we'd take this really sweat because take a sweater.
Just ridiculous.
Ridiculous.
I'm a,
I'm making a bowl of cornflakes disappear because you ate it.
Yeah.
I hate it.
So at its best they go,
this is insane.
These guys are crazy.
And they clapped when they give us five minutes and when it was,
it was the guy.
These people are insane.
This is awful.
And they broke away.
Then we did sword fighting.
That was good because I directed three musketeers that university and uh,
so we would doing,
showing you how to kill someone when drunk when thing,
when you,
when you do,
you know,
all these different moves.
So that was quite fun.
Then I went solo and I was doing escapology from chains and ropes and then from
a five foot unicycle from a pair of manacles escapology meaning I escape Ology
ESCO real thing.
Is that once the apology,
you guys really call it that?
Yeah.
What do you call it?
Oh,
I don't think is a name for it.
Never even heard of that.
I think it,
Google will tell us there is an escape.
Artists,
I know there's escape artists.
Escapology does it exist?
Who?
The word it his word?
There's a thing called a skip ology.
Live escape games were on escape rooms and there's a bunch of them.
I don't know if it's the same thing as escape rooms.
Escape rooms.
Go apology should be a Wiki on art form.
It's almost like it's not right off is a craft.
Well know Houdini was an artist of that.
I was uh,
I was at jumping crofting there.
It is practically escaping from restraints,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
There you go.
Steal Books.
She's barrels,
bags,
things.
So I was escaping from ropes and chains.
And you made a conscious decision to do this like on the street,
like this is how you're developing.
Yeah,
that was developing because I couldn't get my sketch comedy thing wasn't going.
I,
there's a thing called the Edinburgh festival.
We have Scotland.
Yeah.
You know that one.
So I did 12 of those in the ends right before I took her off.
So I did three doing sketch and then about four doing street.
But on the street you have this freedom.
We know the freedom when things of working a bit and,
and it's really kind of feral.
Um,
no one's checking you out.
No one knows what you're doing.
You're just on the street.
So I was useless at this.
And then I developed a confidence,
a gut confidence.
You know that that stomach's really important.
Probably isn't fighting as well.
There's something that comes out of the,
there's a confidence center in the stomach.
Real.
Yeah.
There's something about the stomach.
You,
you look into it with fighting.
I think it's neurons,
right?
It's like there's something,
everything joins the,
there's something to do with it.
Anyway,
I felt I developed this confidence on my own to go and stand on.
If you ever seen had the film,
my fair lady or seen a film of Eliza Doolittle that is set on coven garden,
it's a massive,
Piet said massive square.
Um,
Washington Square Park in New York was another straight before in place.
So it's a big open place and I could stand up that on my own and talk to no one
and build up an audience.
I would set out these tea cozies,
which a little animal tea cozies ducks and hamsters that weird things.
Things that just look like animals and put them on the floor.
And people thought this guy's crazy.
And then I'd start talking and there'll be no,
literally no one there sometimes and I'd take it often.
Then I'm going to do a show.
Welcome to the invisible audience.
Very nice to have you here.
And I had this confidence if I just kept talking a bit like you know in your,
your podcast here,
you know,
you keep talking,
I can queue and I go on.
Yeah we've got to the awesome visible people here as well.
This is Dan is Jack and Kenyans guy.
And I would just go on and on until I built up about 20 people and then I could
start the shower,
then we'd get into it.
And if you're doing an escapology show,
in the end you're going to get out.
You've worked out how to get out.
And so there will be a definite end and then you can say,
now go,
please,
can you give me some money?
So that's how I am my living.
But that's the Ninja training of performing because I learned to perform when
people didn't even want to see me right now.
Cause normally they've cut,
they've come into a room,
at least I go,
okay,
who is this guy?
Then I we're in the room so let's drink a beer and watch.
But if they're on the street,
they don't have to watch.
They can just walk off and they often dead.
So it was a tough,
I have,
I lost all my confidence on the street.
In fact,
I,
in fact I did a thing,
army does this,
you know,
uh,
break you down,
build you back at the marines,
break you,
then build you back out.
Uh,
they also in,
in,
in a drama school,
they break you down and build you buy all this kind of idea.
I accidentally broke myself down and built myself back up on the streets of
London.
So wow.
It's kind of beautiful.
That's why I was creatively born.
Uh,
this,
the version that had this thing.
Okay,
we're going to talk about chickens.
How many chickens did it take to change a light bulb?
Well,
quite a lot.
Ready?
Cause you know,
they can't.
Um,
and as I had a friend with maybe a dog could help them or they could rig up
something.
I just waffle on stuff.
And if he didn't hit a punchline,
I didn't care.
I just carried on,
just kept going.
And then the confidence things Kinda gets you through.
He just talks for hours.
Yeah.